Model pengaturcaraan adalah spesifikasi asas yang menentukan
macam mana perisian distrukturkan
dan dilaksanakan — ia menyediakan rangka kerja
untuk pembangun menyatakan algoritma
dan menyusun kod, selalunya dengan menyembunyikan butiran peringkat rendah
perkakasan atau persekitaran pelaksanaan yang mendasarinya
model yang berbeza sesuai untuk jenis masalah yang berbeza
dan perkakasan berbeza, menawarkan
tahap abstraksi yang pelbagai
dan kawalan. Dalam bab ini,
kita akan mengulas model pengaturcaraan kuantum dan klasik
dan tengok macam mana kita boleh gabungkan keduanya untuk menjalankan algoritma
dalam persekitaran hibrid
kita mulakan dengan model pengaturcaraan
untuk komputer kuantum. Satu model pengaturcaraan asas
yang hampir semua pembangun kuantum dah kenal
ialah quantum circuit. Kita tak akan masuk
ke dalam butiran quantum circuit
di sini sebab kita dah ada banyak sumber yang bagus,
termasuk kuliah oleh Joan Waters.
Kita hanya sebut bahawa circuit dibina daripada
satu set garisan yang dipanggil wayar, yang mewakili qubit,
serta gate yang mewakili operasi ke atas keadaan kuantum,
dan satu set pengukuran.
Satu lagi konsep model pengaturcaraan yang penting
ialah primitif.
Primitif ini mewakili tugas paling popular
yang pengguna cuba lakukan dengan komputer kuantum.
Ada dua primitif yang tersedia pada masa ini:
Sampler dan Estimator. Sampler bagi kamu keupayaan
untuk sampel keadaan yang disediakan oleh quantum circuit,
dan Estimator pula membolehkan kamu menganggar nilai jangkaan
bagi suatu observable untuk sistem dalam keadaan yang disediakan oleh quantum
circuit kamu. Konsep terakhir
yang akan kita bincangkan dalam bahagian ini
ialah transpilasi. Transpilasi
adalah proses menulis semula circuit input yang diberikan
supaya sepadan dengan topologi peranti kuantum
yang tertentu
untuk dilaksanakan pada komputer kuantum berbising.
Sama seperti pengkompil klasik,
rutin transpiler secara beransur-ansur mengubah
struktur circuit dengan menerapkan satu set laluan (passes).
Sekarang jom kita bincang model pengaturcaraan klasik.
Ada banyak model pengaturcaraan
untuk komputer klasik,
tapi dalam bab ini kita fokus pada dua
yang paling popular: pengaturcaraan selari
dan aliran kerja tugasan. Dengan menggunakan dua model ini
bersama model pengaturcaraan kuantum,
seseorang boleh menyatakan hampir mana-mana aliran kerja hibrid
kuantum-klasik dengan apa-apa kerumitan sekalipun.
Model pengaturcaraan selari
membahagikan program kepada sub-masalah yang boleh dilaksanakan
pada masa yang sama. Ada dua paradigma utama pengaturcaraan selari:
perkongsian memori bersama (shared memory) dan memori teragih (distributed memory).
Untuk tujuan kita di sini, jom fokus pada model memori teragih.
Model memori teragih
menggunakan proses bebas pada teras berasingan
atau nod, di mana setiap proses ada memorinya sendiri
dan komunikasi berlaku melalui pengiriman mesej. Ada
beberapa konsep yang berguna untuk diketahui.
Yang pertama ialah proses,
iaitu instans bebas program
yang berjalan pada teras berasingan.
Ada juga rank, iaitu pengecam unik untuk proses tersebut,
dan kemudian ada model abstraksi
single program multiple data (SPMD),
iaitu model abstraksi
untuk pengiraan di mana satu instans program
diedarkan ke beberapa nod.
Jadi kod sumbernya sama,
tapi data pada nod-nod tersebut berbeza.
Model pengaturcaraan selari untuk pelaksanaan
berlaku dengan cara berikut:
satu program diedarkan ke beberapa nod
dan memulakan beberapa proses selari.
Aliran kawalan program ditentukan oleh rank,
iaitu pengecam proses tersebut,
dan komunikasi berlaku
melalui pengiriman mesej.
Model pengaturcaraan aliran kerja tugasan
mengabstrakkan pengiraan dalam bentuk graf atau DAG,
di mana setiap nod graf adalah tugasan atau
kerja tertentu, dan tepi adalah kebergantungan data
serta susunan. Contoh boleh dijumpai dalam dokumentasi kami.
Sebenarnya urutan yang sering kita bincangkan dalam pengkomputeran kuantum —
pemetaan, pengoptimuman,
pelaksanaan dan pemprosesan pasca —
adalah model pengaturcaraan aliran kerja tugasan
di mana semua tugasan dilaksanakan satu demi satu
dalam saluran paip.
Tapi dengan aliran kerja tugasan,
kita tak terikat pada urutan pelaksanaan berjujukan
dan boleh laksanakan tugasan secara selari.
Setiap tugasan atau aliran kerja boleh menjadi kerja selari tersendiri,
jadi kamu boleh gabung
dan padankan model-model ini untuk menerangkan algoritma
dengan kerumitan apa pun.
Jom cuba terapkan beberapa konsep yang kita belajar
dalam kod. Pertama kita cuba jalankan hello world ringkas
menggunakan paradigma pengaturcaraan selari.
Kita akan guna Open MPI,
iaitu implementasi protokol MPI,
yang merupakan standard untuk pengiriman mesej
dalam pengaturcaraan selari.
Pertama kita perlu sediakan program kita.
Di sini kita guna mpi4py,
iaitu binding Python
untuk MPI. Dan macam yang kamu nampak, kita guna rank di sini untuk tentukan
aliran kawalan program.
Jom tengok skrip submission kita.
Macam yang kamu nampak, kita akan guna dua nod,
satu tugasan per nod dalam partition normal.
Jom jalankan program kita — kita tunggu sekejap
dan boleh semak keputusan kerja kita.
Macam yang kamu nampak, kita ada output log program kita.
Di sini kita guna dua nod dan dua proses
yang dikenal pasti dengan rank.
Macam yang kamu nampak dalam output,
rank sifar dan rank satu digunakan untuk tentukan
aliran kawalan program kita.
Macam yang kamu nampak, proses rank sifar menghantar
muatan data tertentu ke proses rank satu,
dan proses rank satu menerimanya.
Kita juga akan bincang aliran kerja tugasan.
Ada alat yang dipanggil sistem
pengurusan aliran kerja. Ia direka khusus
untuk menjalankan aliran kerja yang kompleks.
Tapi supaya tak terlalu membebankan, kita akan guna ciri kebergantungan terbina dalam
dalam Slurm
untuk membina kumpulan pengiraan tersebut.
Pertama kita perlu sediakan tugasan aliran kerja kita —
ini kod yang sama.
Kelebihan memisahkan setiap tugasan ini —
iaitu pemetaan, pengoptimuman, pelaksanaan
dan pemprosesan pasca — sebagai langkah berasingan
ialah kita boleh tentukan keperluan sumber yang unik
untuk setiap tugasan. Contohnya, pemetaan, pengoptimuman,
dan pemprosesan pasca tidak memerlukan
akses kepada sumber kuantum,
jadi kita boleh jalankannya pada partition klasik.
Tapi tugasan pelaksanaan memerlukan
sumber kuantum, jadi kita akan jalankannya pada
partition kuantum.
Sekarang jom guna ciri kebergantungan untuk rantaikan tugasan
ke dalam aliran kerja.
Macam yang kamu nampak, kita masih menjalankan
arahan sbatch kita dengan bendera --parsable,
yang akan kembalikan ID kerja,
dan kemudian kita boleh hantar ID kerja ini
sebagai kebergantungan kepada tugasan lain.
Untuk kerja-kerja ini, macam yang kamu nampak, kita menjalankan
kerja dalam aliran kerja dengan kebergantungan.
Setelah keseluruhan aliran kerja selesai, kita boleh semak keputusannya.
Dan macam yang kamu nampak, kita dapat nilai jangkaan kita balik.
Dan kita juga boleh semak semua
keputusan dari setiap langkah.
Yang memang ada di sini.
Itulah sahaja untuk bahagian model pengaturcaraan.
Dalam bab seterusnya kita akan bincang tentang algoritma lanjutan.
Jumpa lagi.